there's an actor named Tom Holland oh
yeah I am mistaken for him all the time
so like and what's your name and they go
Tom Holland cuz they've heard Tom
Holland the Tom Holland they go no it's
Tom Holland
dur and people in the accounts
Department of my agency got confused and
we were with the same agency and I got
an email from the agency saying payment
advice slip your um first box office
bonus for the Avengers I don't think I'm
in Avengers am I I mean I've been
working a long time I don't remember
remember doing the Avengers it was an
astonishing amount of money and it was
it was not his salary it was it was his
first box office bonus not the whole box
of the first one and it was more money
than I've ever it was it was a seven
figure sum and then I felt utterly
crushed when I saw how much money he was
earning and he was like 19 when the
reviews come out for this and he gets
mistaken for you he's gonna be Cry he's
gonna send me some money he's gonna send
me some Spider-Man money